how are you doing someone is asking me
you said someplace that you felt like
you were at times dancing on broken
glass no I think I said that I was I
always felt like I was dancing on broken
glass are you getting enough rest and
R&R is the food sensitivity getting
worked out I think maybe the food
sensitivity thing is getting worked out
I think it's out the basis of this
depression that's been plaguing my
family for generations but I haven't
figured out exactly what it is yet I'm
working very hard on that with my
daughter who also seems to have the same
problem and it is absolutely brutal
it's absolutely brutal so am I getting
enough rest and R&R that's hard to say
because with the responses that I've
been having that have knocked my health
back it's it's hard to discriminate
between rest and R&R the lack of that
and just getting walloped by by eating
what appears to be the wrong thing so
it's so funny because you know for years
I was very skeptical of anyone who was
concerned about you know gluten
sensitivity and that sort of thing but I
sure learned that that was arrogant so
yeah well I found many times in my life
that you have to be aware of what you
are judgmental about because many things
come back to haunt you